hey everybody and welcome to another HD
tutorial and in this video I'll be
showing you how to have actually more
than one dock on your screen for example
in this video I have two knots the first
one is my rocket dock down here and you
can go ahead and watch my video or
several videos on rocketdock the second
video at the second dock at the top of
the screen is object dock okay I'm going
to show you guys how to get object dock
so that you can go actually have two
docks on your screen at once so you will
have one for applications and one for
folders I'll show you exactly how to do
that so here's what we're gonna do open
up any web browser okay for this one I'm
going to use Safari and any popular
search engines such as Google I'm going
to type in object object dock okay this
is going to take you the first result
right here is object comm just click on
it and it'll take you to the star deck
star dock object dock page [ __ ] get
rid of this so here's the start up star
dock object page it is a freeware
application first of all and it is it
does have a lot of popular features at
both rocket dock and some other versions
of the rocket dock do you have but what
we're going to do is just click on the
free download button so we can have more
than one dock on our page there is a
plus version that is actually $20 and
then there is a free version we're going
to try to get the free version here just
by hitting the download button so once
we get it it'll bring us to the C net
download link okay we're going to get
the latest version just click on it and
it'll actually instantly begin your
download now I'm not going to go through
the installation process number one
because I already have it and number two
because this is a very very simple
installation process so I'll hit cancel
but if you do want it just hit just go
ahead and hit run if you didn't hit run
if you hit save it'll save it to a place
like on your desktop just go ahead and
double click it and allow UAC to pop up
and everything and finish with your
installation
once you finish your installation you'll
have a dock just like this one okay now
you have officially two docks on your
screen and all of them work the same way
as rocketdock does right so if you do
have any questions about it hopefully
I'll be able to get more customization
tutorials etc with you guys so I'll be
able to go over customization with this
and plenty of other videos but there you
go by request you now have two docks on
your screen and if you ever feel like
customizing it here is to configure dock
button click on it you can change it to
be at the top of your page okay and you
can choose it to reserve the edge of
your screen which is nice if you don't
want anything to pop up over it just
like Mac os10
so I'll just open up a full screen
browser here and there you go it
reserves the top edge of your screen so
there you guys go you have two web route
you two have two docks now if you have
any other tutorial requests or ideas for
me I'm glad to help you just go ahead
and subscribe and send me a request
video and I will try to get to it as
best as I can so thanks for the requests
and thanks for watching this video and
thanks and hopefully you'll subscribe
peace